so you know what man we're gonna top it
all off with the best the best Gen Z is
dragging Millennials for being pathetic
and they're correct yes 100% kids this
is years we are in complete agreement
yep
you know generation is trash yeah we
talked about what a millennial is in the
show I think last week and after that
show someone hit me up and they were
like you know what I wanted to let you
know Adam you're not a millennial and I
was like why do tell me and they were
like it's it's not just years it's a
it's state of mind and the the year
thing is is so flexible they keep
pushing it back in the 80s but it's like
you can push it the other way too sorry
you could push both ways playing
tug-of-war I'm not a millennial I don't
feel I am I think Millennials suck I
think they're entitled they have no idea
what they have and you and none of us
screech none of us here fit the
stereotype of what the Jen's ears say
like they think Harry Potter has a
personality trait you've never actually
even read it I don't know what Harry
Potter's like I know he's got a I got a
on his the lightning bolt is a lightning
ball game one of the funniest things was
that I pretty sure was Jen see same as a
few years ago like these younger kids
pointing out that all of these protests
these people were making Harry Potter
protest signs they were saying things
like Trump is Voldemort and it's like is
that it is that all your gap you've read
one book read a different book dude yes
please please book they Fred Casely
read read some some real stuff mister
watch some documentary dude I watched I
watched some of these tic TOCs from gen
z mocking millennials nailed it
completely nailed it and the funny thing
is I was like I tweeted this I'm like
you realize they're not talking about
conservatives conservative Millennials
are posting frog memes yeah they're not
getting mocked Gen Z isn't mocking
people for their frog memes no no
they're mocking people for their
avvocato toast coffee and complaining
because someone called them a naughty
word on the internet now avocado toast
yeah delicious but I'm pretty sure
everyone can agree
avocado toast it's pretty good avocados
are great yeah but it's like this
stereotypical hipster urban millennial
thing of like but when you eat it every
single day
and you start whining and you porno $12
or $15 on avocado and you're not making
it yourself your millennial yeah have
you seen the deconstructed trend no
what's this so it's like a hipster thing
where you go to the restaurant and
you'll be like I'll have the
deconstructed you know omelette and it's
a tortilla it's like they don't just
don't make it just believe it so you can
get deconstructed sandwiches and it's
literally just they give you the
ingredients stuff yep here you go sir
it's this that'll be $30 there's also
there's also a subreddit called we want
plates okay and it's like a hipster
restaurant trend of putting things on
random hijack wood all right yeah like
there was one a while ago and I thought
was hilarious because they gave someone
like pancakes with syrup but it was
served on a piece of wood so the syrup
was pouring off onto the table yeah and
they're like there's a reason plates are
kind of you know are concave concave so
that it stays in yeah dude I am I I
think you know the 80s were crazy time
yeah whenever I look back to the 80s
that was like the Gen Xers with it when
they were like young or coming to their
teens and you know what yeah go ahead
you say lecture people wore like skin
tight hot pants with like hot pink
leopard print while rollerskating and it
was a weird thing about tell you what
that was a million times cooler than
whatever the guys are doing seriously I
think it's a product of who you grow up
around - I have a lot of cousins like a
lot I have like over 40 cousins not
crazy
yeah cousins all on my dad's side alone
yeah so big family but I had a lot I had
a lot of older cousins so growing up in
the 80s I was surrounded by my cousins
that were six seven eight years older
than me so I was surrounded by that
crowd
I was I was not necessarily raised but I
was certainly influenced by like the
older generation but right before me so
I think that's that's kind of why I'm
like what are these Millennials thinking
what are they doing I don't you know I
think it is I think Millennials that the
ones that we talk about they're very
active on social media they're the the
members of our generation who who were
late to the party on the internet so I
think about I've been on the Internet as
long as I've been alive my my mom had
CompuServe through DOS you remember dial
up the
well yeah do that I do too
most money ins do but now I'm talking
about das shell you know das jealous
when if just the blinking dot and you
have to like all time well the shell was
actually one step beyond the blinking
dot really so the so you had the the
command prompt which is the first
computers we had and you went online
through typing in you know going to
CompuServe and then das shell gave you
the sort of graphical interface where
you could see the list and press down
and highlight them and press ENTER and I
had all the old-school games on Das and
then we finally I remember getting
Windows 3.1 so we did we've had the
internet forever
yeah and i-i've always been online and
then you know it started with chat rooms
and then social media emerged as well so
I think you know for sure yeah oh LMAO
chat rooms the people that I know thing
who were on the internet very early are
all about the spicy memes they're all
about pranks and silliness and just
jokes and the people I know who weren't
because they were like their parents
made them go to soccer practice or
whatever and they were like growing up
in the suburbs like you know they
weren't online so when they finally got
online they were just like it was like
being injected straight into their veins
and they no tolerance for it yeah and
they went insane well in the difference
is like when you get made fun of in
school you know that there's like a
social aspect that you're used to in
reality and like not in the internet
world in the internet realm you know you
can feel the nuance of everything you
could talk about it with your friends
cuz they saw it and they're like oh man
don't worry that guy was an a-hole like
we got you but on the internet you're on
your own you're you're paddling in this
huge ocean of nothingness and it's like
if you if that's all you know and you
haven't like gotten thick skin from like
some real reality interactions with
bullies or because they're out there
they exist and then the internet every
bully sees you all the bullies are like
it's a small fish each it's time to
consume there's layers I can see it if
you don't know what you're going in
you're going in blind
you're gonna get eaten it's a delirium
it's a psychosis yeah so there's two big
ideas that are kind of bubbling up right
now about what's wrong with with these
Millennials and what's wrong what's
going on with social media
Brett Weinstein talked about this
Twitter and then on the Joe Rogan
podcast that the Chinese interrogation
techniques to break an American soldier
was really really brilliant they used
really low-level
incremental tactics the general idea
being gets someone to admit in writing
they have to write themselves something
seemingly innocuous that's negative
about their position so the first thing
the Chinese would do would say they
would say ok if you want food we want
you to write America is not perfect and
everyone will be like of course it's not
yeah that's reasonable ok they write it
and then from there you can increment
them slowly into writing more and more
bad things now what they would do is
they would give them a very tiny reward
the reason was if they gave him a really
big reward like a big meal then the
person could rationalize it I lied in
order to get a big reward giving him a
small reward the person could write
something bad about the United States
and they couldn't justify it because the
reward wasn't really worth it but they
did want that little piece of fruit or
something right yeah if they're starving
I mean so this is what one of things
that Brett was talking about it's you
you you take that idea put it on the
internet and you have this willful drive
towards doing this thing but I wonder
how much China might might actually be
involved in running bad accounts to
nudge people to make them write these
things but think about it these people
keep one-upping themselves writing
crazier and crazier things thinking it's
reasonable because they're getting a
tiny reward had that big of a deal it's
a few likes to few retweets yeah so
every day they one-up it and now they've
driven themselves insane the other thing
that that's that's been going around
someone sent me this that there is a
dopamine addiction stimulus stimulant
it's it's a social media stimuli like
stimulant effect yeah where every time
you check your phone you get a dopamine
hit especially when they know but but
but I don't know I'm dead serious it's
like you get it oh they like my post and
people like my think about think about
how we quantify how many viewers we have
how many likes we have I know oh my how
many super chats yeah
and I'll tell you what man you can see
it in youtubers when they have low
mental fortitude and it's most of them
it's almost all of them be honest one
day like look at their look wait till
some some youtuber has a breakdown
mm-hmm where they're like I just don't
know if I'd keep through this bad and
then look at their view
and there if you count the days before
we'll be in a downward slope yeah so
what happens is they'll work really hard
to make a video to get a million views
the next day 700,000 the next day 500
and then by day three they're at 400 and
the next day they look I can't do any
more and they talk about all these
things that have nothing to do with
what's really happening you know they're
having they're not getting the dopamine
hit their addiction is not getting
satisfied exactly but here's what here's
what they ended up saying in this in
this thread that I was son when these
people these millennial social justice
types open up their phone to get that
hit of dopamine they need to put out a
tweet that's that's gonna give them
those clicks that attention those likes
mm-hmm so they're one upping themselves
and now this comes into the Chinese you
know manipulation technique but every
time they open up their phone and do it
two things are happening one they're
radicalizing themselves to there they're
building their addiction and so the the
the the Delirium ideas going on I don't
call it a theory exam I don't know these
people are doctors is that when you're
on stimulants non-stop it really fries
your brain and like builds up aggression
and like intolerance
well there's yeah there's literally a
tolerance to any kind of drug I think
you can have dopamine exhaustion like
you can just get too much and then
you're like completely like numb to it
so I'm wonder if that's part of what's
happening well with what they were
saying is that basically it's a
psychosis when you when you do
stimulants too often all the time yeah
and you get so much dopamine released
you start going insane well then you
think about the average diet you know I
like how much sugar average you know
person consumes it's like sugar is the
same thing this is a reward system that
like oh I let me have a treat and
something sugary you know and the brain
gets like oh yeah so roars oh wait oh I
got likes it's the same thing so I did I
did a segment the other day about this
woman who firebombs some Philadelphia
police vehicles okay
that's got caught her mom because she's
a more hoe I saw this right all right so
they so this woman Etsy right through a
theater tattoo through Etsy so she was
wearing a shirt that said something like
keep the immigrants deport the racists
okay so they did a search for the shirt
found out that it was fairly unique
found a review on
Celer Oh what this person's name no way
and they tracked the person found photos
eventually found a photo with a tattoo
and they're like boom we got her Wow
what's amazing about that is that I am I
am unimpressed with the FBI's ability to
do that because I've been doing that
since the inception of the not like when
I when I worked for Vice I would show
people how to do basic internet
investigations and sleuthing mm-hmm I
used to do this trick where whenever I
would meet someone and we were doing
some kind of business deal okay I would
like ask them their name and then while
they were talking I would pull up all
their private information now dock them
in real time and then what I would say
is this I'd be after they talked and
introduce themselves I'd be like right
on right on man well hey I'll tell you
what tonight we have a party I don't
know if you want to come you have time
it's not gonna be too crazy it's gonna
be kind of get together and they go yeah
where's it at and I'll be like one two
three fake Street in you know North
Hollywood California and they go what
and then I'm like yeah that's where the
party's at they'll be like that's my
address how about I know it is it was
kind of like a it's kind of like to show
you but this this this was particularly
when I was doing that's a little creepy
the programming Oh totally but but this
was back when I was hanging out
hackerspaces Lydia agrees when I first
started talking to Tim he basically did
that to me whoa he was like oh I'm gonna
learn all about you so he got me talking
and I was talking about he's hired or
whatever this is this is this is back
when I used to hang out at hackerspaces
okay and so I'll tell you what man that
these these people know what you're
thinking I'm sure that yeah there was
one time where this one guy we're
sitting at a party and he and he he's
talking to a bunch of people and he goes
and he points over to a man and a woman
okay and then he started he started
predicting everything they would do and
it was perfect he would be like in three
seconds the girl's gonna laugh three two
and then she laughs and everyone talks
and then we all start laughing I was now
the guy he's gonna shift his shoulders
and turn towards her three two and then
he does because these guys were social
engineers and he was explaining all of
the really obvious stereotypical
behaviors these people do yeah but
anyway and not to get too much into that
the point I was bringing up is that you
have this very predictable behavior with
the internet mm-hmm you have people who
are becoming addicted to getting this
hit you know they're literally going
insane
and now to go back to the woman who got
caught by the FBI she in the photos they
found was a normal looking woman and I
started thinking about I mentioned this
in the video that there's a meme that's
called something like feminism not even
once mmm doesn't those methods it was be
like methamphetamine not even once
no I don't it would show a picture of a
regular person okay and then it would
show them after they were out like oh
yeah drug-addled and messed up they're
gone so people start making memes where
was like feminism not even once and it
shows these people before they go to
college and afterwards and it is
terrifying like de Blasio's daughter yes
yeah yeah that's where they're like big
smiling and normal and my regular
clothes like this and the next one is
their heads are all shape and they're
like snarling at the camera like weird
freaky people golems golems and so you
have this this woman with the fire bomb
it's so sad because it's it's I've seen
so much of this the the photo they found
of her was a normal young woman and the
pictures of her in Philadelphia was
nightmarish wow really nappy like
smashed dreads like huge belly and just
like hunched over yet no dude like 30 or
40 pounds heavier okay you're being nice
just like just and I was like I'm not
saying this to be mean to her right but
this looks like a before-and-after of a
drug addict and the crazy thing is a lot
of these people are but a lot of them
aren't it's something happen to them
that's transforming their brains and to
like its withering their brain I think
there's I don't I don't think it's just
the social justice at the universities
like they're being indoctrinated I think
that plays a role in making them in
radicalizing them but I think it has a
lot to do with their addiction to social
media it's almost like probably other
things so someone in the chat just said
it's probably adderall too yeah I know a
lot of people that went to college that
they're like I would not have made it
through all the studying staying up all
night without whatever they were on but
I'll tell you what man the people I know
so I used to hang out at the Columbia
dorms in Chicago okay and I knew a lot
of regular people a lot of them today
have gone insane and are like drug out
and all that stuff
and it was because they were taking at a
roll for sure yep
a lot of them were but it was because
they wanted to do it all they wanted to
go on party yeah
and do their homework instead of being
like I can't go out today guys I got to
do my homework they'd be like I'll go
out I'll just take a pill and then they
they like that you know what man it's
probably a bit esoteric but for those of
you that are fans of World of Warcraft
it reminds me of the night born elves
their story is that they became addicted
to a magic well and then when the
Magic's like long story short when the
magic was taken from them a bunch of
them slowly started to wither and become
mindless like shriveled up like and they
run around like just brain-dead zombies
yeah but it's it you know it's it's it's
the same thing for the blood elves too
but it that's just a basic idea about
drug addiction and withdrawal okay these
people have been addicted to the
stimulant of social media their brains
are hooked to it they you know you know
let me tell you something bro I was
working on an app with a buddy of mine
years ago and the goal that the idea for
the app was whenever you checked your
time on your phone whenever you click it
to see what time it is you would be
served a news story and so it was a news
delivery app for your lockscreen okay
and when the idea was was brought up to
me by my buddy I said I mean that's a
cool idea but don't we already have
notifications and he was like yeah but
typically the notifications you get are
few and far between this is specifically
a news story whenever you check your
phone and I was like yeah but come on
what you take your phone like two or
three times a day honey goes 140 yeah is
the average the average person's like
140 140 140 times they checked their
phone and he was like so we do is every
tenth viewing is an advertisement and so
then we're getting 14 ads per person per
day and that's huge yeah that's insane
and I was like whoa so he ended up
making a whole company based on that and
we did our project together but news was
like we don't we don't we never actually
had any ads in it okay but but him
telling me that like we looked it over
and yep it's like a hundred and forty
times per day people will check their
phones
wow that is an addiction then you throw
in what these people on Twitter are
doing and its really obvious why they're
addicted they need it they need those
buttons they do the likes that's true so
now now you have this one dude what's
his name
Palmer what's his name you know Palmer
report whatever Palmer report guy yeah
literally to Twitter thread saying it's
time to re-educate conserve
because they're going insane they're
addicted they have a stimulant hooked to
their brain Wow
peeing that dopamine over and over and
over again and now they're literally
going to the point where they're like
burn it all down and lock them in camps
cuz if you want to get the shares you
can't post the same thing you posted
yesterday it's true you gotta one-up
yourself over and over and over again
and now that the point of complete
absurdity nothing makes sense
everything's breaking down you got
politicians who are listening to this
could you imagine if your politicians
were like I hear what you're saying
homeowner and an entrepreneur but I'm
gonna take the advice from the drug
addict
you'd be like but that's not a good
person isn't unwell right so now you've
got 70 it's 2% of the population they're
active on Twitter 2% percent right now
22% of the population has a Twitter
account okay
think about the 78% of regular people
who have nothing to do with Twitter and
don't even know what's going on that's
what that's the people I've refer to all
the time the people who are gonna show
up to Philly with baseball bats like
don't do it on our statue yeah wait wait
people are tearing down statues no no no
that's it we're going out there these
when they come into our town mm-hmm it's
gonna happen and it's happening already
we're see it is yeah thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you